こんちは！はじめしゃちょーです
ただいまの時刻なんですけども
２月１３日２３時５１分
あと9分で僕の誕生日でございます
すぅ～↗
～♪(iPhoneの音)
もうすぐ僕も23歳になるわけなんですけれども
ここまできちゃうとぉぉぉ～
あんまりうれしくないですね
なんか22(歳)までまだよかったんですよ
こう、なんか"大人になったな"って
感じがあったんですけども
22(歳)と23(歳)にはなぜか大きな壁があるイメージがあって
ちょっとね、もう、おっさんですよ。
23(歳)となったらもうおっさんなんですもぉ↑
これからもね、あんまり今までと変わらず
面白くない大人にならないように
ハチャメチャなことやっていこうと思います
23歳になっても宜しくお願いいたします
ていうかちょっとTwitterの方なんですけども、
ちょっと見てみましょう
少し早いけどハッピーバースデー
おわーすごい、ってこれはブルーベリーだ！
ほんとに、ほんとにすごい大勢の方から
お祝いのメッセージをいただいております！
本当にありがとうございます！
2月14日、バレンタインデーなんですけども
僕は今年の目標にある通り
お菓子を食べません。
つまり僕の誕生日と言いつつ、僕はもう
チョコも食べれないんで
大事なんでもう一回言いましょう。
チョコレートが食べれないんですよ！
今回の動画なんですけども
ネットとかこういう場所では結構祝っていただいて
ありがたいんですけども
僕はリアルは方はどうなのかと
その、チョコも貰えない
チョコも貰えないとなると
誰が祝ってくれるのかって話ですよ
なんで今日はですね
僕の誕生日の一日で
どれぐらい、もう、リアルな友達に
祝ってもらえるかっていうのを
ちょっと検証しようと思います。
(早送り)
一日中、家にいてみようかと思います。
もう誰にも連絡しないよ
なんかすげぇ寂しがり屋みたいだな(笑)
寂しがり屋みたいになっちゃうんですけども
誕生日、一日中家にいて
誰に、どれくらい祝ってもらえるのかを
ちょっと、純粋に家にいてみようと思います。
僕のリアルは、どれくらい
友達とかいるのかっていうのがねぇ
部屋の壁に書いちゃったの？
嘘だw
あと5分だ
(早送り)
あと3分でございます。
いやも〜ね、なんかね
いろんな人にお祝いしてもらって僕は幸せでございます(涙)
ほんとにありがとうございます
ネットでは。
現実はそうあまくないんですよね〜。
あっおっあっ！
誕生日なっちゃった！
はい！０時になりました！
にじゅう……3歳でございます！
ぱぱぱぱぱぱ(拍手)
みんなありがとう(喜)
すごい！コメントがもう
おめでとうもろこし…
わー皆さんありがとうございます…！
ほんとにありがとうみんなもぉ〜……
ちょ、できるだけお気に入りしよ
(早送り)
リアルの方は…まだ誰もきていません（笑）
わぁああすごいよこれとかマジで
なつかし〜ぃ⤴︎これ
富山県の番組で誕生日祝ってくれるんですよこういう
(早送り)
中国からか…！
えぇ？！
(泣く)
ｽﾝｯ……(鼻をすする)
勘弁してくれ〜ぃ(涙)
ｽﾝｯ
ぁちょwちょまっww(泣)
なんでこの画像にした（笑）
ありがとうございます(涙)
すごいねこれ、中国のファンの皆さんなんですね…！
国を超えてみてもらうとなると
うるってきまふね(涙)
いえいえほんとにありがとうございます(涙)
国とか関係なくみてもらえるととても嬉しいです…
泣く予定じゃなかったんだけどなー
(早送り)
？
後輩A:ハッピバースデートゥーユー♪
ハッピバースデートゥーユー♪
ハッピバースデーディア
はーじめ〜〜んっ♪
ハーピバースデートゥーユー♪
おめでとーおおおおおおおおお！！！
おめでとおおおおおおおお！！(拍手)
あぶねあぶねww
23ですよ
頑張って見てたんだよ
(バン！！！！) わぁぁぁああ！！！！
いぇーーーーーい！！！
パチパチパチパチ(拍手)
ごくごく
ぶっふ
パソコンがぁ(汗
社会人としてのはじめしゃちょーの
活躍に期待してます。これからも頑張ってください。
(早送り)
おやすみなさいっ
12時52分
お昼までちょっと寝てました〜
まだ今のとこ後輩が1人しかきていません
もうちょっと待ってみましょう
(ｶﾞﾁｬ)
後輩B:ううぇええええぇえ〜〜い
(ﾊﾟﾝｯｯ！！！！)ハッピバースデ〜！！
お誕生日おめでとうございます
ありがとうございます！
誕生日プレゼントありますよ
え？ほんとに〜？(わくわく)
これは使えますねwwwありがとうございますww
(早送り)
うお、まじぃ？！？！
まじで？！？！？！
まじで〜？！？！
なんでこんなことしてんのまってw
マジで言ってんすか？！
ありがとうございます
え、すごーい！！！
なんでこんなことした？！
ケーキをいただきました！
まじで言ってんすか、えぇ？！
フゥ〜
パチパチパチパチ(拍手)
お菓子はもう
イチゴだけ食べるよ
ありがとね！！
いただきます
モグモグ
まじで食べてない
(早送り)
え、サプライズ？！え？！
え、ほんとにいいの？！
えへへ！！うそじゃん〜
え、え、これはダメだよ〜
あwりwがwとwうww
え、ホントに言ってんの〜？
まじぃ〜？！
ちょっとまってwセイキンさんにケーキ食べていいよって言われたw
セイキンさんに言われたら食べれるっていう条件があって
セイキンさんからケーキを食べていいって言う命令がきたので
ケーキたべまああああす！！！！！！！(拍手)
(喜び)
まぁ、誕生日だしね〜
後輩C:うっす！
おつかれーす！
なになにぃ？！
ハピバースデーー！！！！
炭酸水ねwww
(結局はじめんはケーキを食べれないのであった)
食べないでおこう！！！
ちょ、ケーキあるからみんな食べていいよ！
ハイッチーズ
もうなんか、ふつーに誕生会じゃんw
ｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ
はい、というわけでぶじ誕生日が終わりました〜！
まだ今日は終わってないんですけども
YouTuberには編集という作業があるので
夜は編集になると思います
Twitterにもものすごい数のコメントをいただいて
いいねに規制がかかるくらいのコメントをいただきました
ほんとにありがとうございます
思ったよりリアルでもたくさん友達がいることがわかりました
こういう事されるとね〜静岡から出たくなくなるんすよ〜
なんやかんや仲間から恵まれており
静岡で楽しく暮らしております！
まぁこの先僕がねどこいくかわかんないんですけど
人生は楽しければいいと思っているんで
23歳もなんかこうハチャメチャなことしいこうと思っております！
23歳のはじめしゃちょーもヨロシクお願いします！
じゃあな☆